night has fallen here in Hong Kong and
the city is coming alive showing one of
its most iconic aspects the neon lights
[Music]
here in Hong Kong neon lights make up a
quintessential part of the visual
culture and the aesthetic of the streets
here during the Golden Age of neon the
diffused glow of this cityscape was
enshrined in film helping to form the
unique Hong Kong cinematic style dark
dense chaotic futuristic and illuminated
by this soft glow of Neel this style
spread beyond Hong Kong in forming the
aesthetics of Japanese comics and anime
like ghost in the shell' and popular
American blockbusters like Blade Runner
[Music]
but even though neon is woven into the
cultural fabric of this place
these lights are quickly faded
[Music]
so what are neon lights and what places
do they have in Hong Kong's urban
culture today let's go visit probably
the perfect person answer that question
the legendary master wu who is a neon
craftsman johnny come by once a client
sends him a design to work off of Master
Wu starts by heating up a glass tube so
that it's malleable and then he starts
bending it to form his design once he
has the shape that he wants he needs to
put gas neon gas into this glass tube
that will see no telephone
Venga height height pop the toilet so he
vacuums out all the air and uses a
series of knobs and machines to pump in
a mixture of gas mostly neon or argon he
seals on an electric unit that will feed
electrical current into this tube once
he plugs this into an electricity source
the gas in the tube responds and begins
to glow different colors depending on
what gases he's used the old ones are
gone I'm gonna do I am gonna enjoy
anything I do
baby whether the golden age for neon
started around the 1970s
this meant that neon lights were
everywhere people were competing for the
best neon lights the best signs and the
designs got really big and really
sophisticated really fast and then
things started to change for the worse
for neon
yeah yeah I'm gonna bag up Delhi led
[Music]
these signs look like they're neon
they're built in the aesthetic of neon
but they're actually LEDs see the
difference that's a neon that is an LED
weight cheaper way more efficient way
easier to install and while LED is easy
to mass-produce
making neon signs it's more of a craft
to take significant time to master seems
you ollie Hawks it hugs your joy it
really does I can walk there mal easy to
do I saw him having Emma but this is
also a matter of city policy the Hong
Kong government started raising safety
concerns with these big neon signs
especially the ones that hung over the
street they created safety codes and
started taking down signs that were in
violation which were quite a few in
recent years thousands of signs have
been taken down slowly changing the
visual landscape of the city the West
Kowloon cultural district has started
curating neon signs and documenting the
stories behind them and as for Master Wu
even though neon lights are disappearing
he still feels optimistic I am noise
though he got don't
Tony Coyle dr. curlew Poonam Paul hi oh
yeah cool a long case are you gonna
hoist on where you are you can Banton it
can be eating high Stern that should be
music pocket
[Music]
[Applause]